bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le mouvement ne
faiblit pas on le voit aujourd'hui face
à cette proposition de loi jugée
liberticide par les manifestants mais
aussi des ong même de grands organismes
internationaux
une loi qui a aussi ses défenseurs quel
est aujourd'hui votre position sur un
support et variées au sénat la
prochainement mes collègues de
poursuivre des auditions et cette loi a
été qualifié par un de mes collègues
fiba qui est quelqu'un de mesuré
comment ayant été écrite avec les pieds
c'est problématique pour loin qui doit
définir ce qui est permis et pas permis
donc il y a eu à l'assemblée nationale
1300 amendements vont pouvoir entrer
dans les différents amendements en
quelques en quelques minutes et
simplement cette loi a cristallisé un et
contentement déjà je pense sur cette loi
de 2 et se sécurité globale l'emphase
démo ne correspond pas à la réalité du
pays et là encore les français sent bien
que c'est de la communication pour une
loi de sécurité
on parle de pas du sentiment
d'insécurité de l'insécurité réelle que
subissent les français nous avons déjà
un certain nombre d'éléments
il y avait deux articles qui ont
cristallisé l'article 22 sur les drogues
effectivement aux questions et un autre
surtout l'article sur l'article 24 sur
la de l'interdiction de filmer de
diffuser des images de policiers aux
gens là il a dans la façon dont est
écrit cet article
il y à redire car ça ne passera pas je
pense le conseil constitutionnel donc le
problème c'est que cette loi dite de
sécurité globale aujourd'hui on sait
pour amener de la sécurité dans les
lieux oui les français on connaît la
plupart c'est tous les mêmes qu'ils
retirent commence à faire des actes de
violence de vol non sur les personnes
il ya une part énorme des récidivistes
ou d'hériter rist est également il ya un
problème en ce moment majeur des dix
mineurs 10
et il fournit la plupart du temps ni
mineur ni isolé qui causent plus de 70%
des actes de délinquance en région ile
de france
donc les problèmes sont déjà identifiés
mais cette loi ne s'attaque pas du tout
à ces phénomènes qui paient qui pénalise
nos concitoyens ont le manque de places
de prison et vous avez au sein de ce
gouvernement
un gentil qui s'appelle dupond moretti
qui va être très content ou qu'ils
expriment d'avoir vidé les prisons lors
du confinement est un monsieur darmanin
qu'il fait l'office de méchant est en
fête qui fait que que des cultes que de
que des propos que dès que des lois avec
ses 7,7 en face qui les caractérise
c'est exagéré ce que la caractérise le
seul point commun des deux c'est qu'ils
sont tous les deux mis en examen alors
beaucoup de manifestants parle de dérive
autoritaire on les entendait au micro de
rts que vous comprenez leur sentiment
moi je comprends tout à fait parce qu'il
ya un vrai recul des libertés en france
depuis plus d'un an savait déjà commencé
avant mais simplement bien sûr les lois
de restriction alors lié rattachés par
le gouvernement à la loi d'urgence
sanitaire que j'ai refusé de voter moi
cette semaine au sénat mais liberté de
circuler les nécessités de faire des
attestations daniel découvre son liberté
pour les médecins de prescrire liberté
d'exercer pour tout les acteurs tout le
monde de la culture du désespoir donc de
la restauration donc à une vraie
atteinte aux libertés fondamentales qui
liberté de vivre et d'exister et et moi
je comprends tout à fait cette
exaspération
parce que je la partage aujourd'hui moi
je passe des fois des des dizaines
d'oeuvres de 10 heures dans un hémicycle
nous sommes deux sens je ne vois pas
pourquoi dans un théâtre les français ne
pourraient pas aller au théâtre avec
bien sûr toutes les mesures qu'elle des
mesures de ces de sécurité et de
salubrité publique
on a un pays qui a choisi de de
restreindre les libertés comme beaucoup
ne l'ont pas fait autour de nous et les
médias ne parlent sauf les médias comme
comme le vôtre de que la grande bretagne
ont fini durement que l'allemagne mais
et beaucoup d'autres pays n'ont pas
choisi cette voie là
choisi de laisser les restaurants
ouverts ou choisi des scellés les
stations de montagne ouvert et donc là
le ce gouvernement là et ce président là
on choisit de priver les français de la
plupart de leurs libertés qui sont
consubstantiels à l'art de vivre à la
française de pouvoir déjeuner dans un
restaurant de pouvoir aller voir une
pièce de théâtre de pouvoir aller au
cinéma et c'est vrai que ça devient de
plus en plus incompréhensible
il ya des ordres il ya des concurrents
et donc il ya du désordre il ya surtout
une perte de confiance totale dans ce
gouvernement qui est en plus incapable
de protéger les français
parce que lorsque vous avez les
manifestations de black blocks lorsque
vous avez vu donc l'arc de triomphe
saccagés ce n'était jamais jamais arrivé
donc là ce gouvernement est incapable
affaires à faire réagir à régir la rue
et je quand je parle de régir la rue
c'est laisser les gens de manifester sa
un droit fondamental et tant qu'il n'y a
pas de désordre il n'y a pas de raison
d'avoir des mesures qui sont des mesures
d'ordre qui sont exagérées et ce
gouvernement l'a montré à de nombreuses
reprises et gilet jaune qui ont été pour
certains au début au moins gmt les
manifestants pacifiques ont été durement
traité et un certain nombre d'entre eux
ont été blessés
ce qui est quand même dans un dé
mocratie qui se dit qui se prétend
libéral inquiétant est par contre les
libertés j'en ai été victime il ya
quelques semaines sur les médias sur les
réseaux sociaux les twitter et facebook
porte atteinte aux libertés y compris
les parlementaires et la l'état français
est bien inaudible et n'entend pas
s'attaquer comme peuvent le faire des
pays comme la pologne comme la hongrie
ou cette dérive inacceptable ou c'est
twitter facebook qui permet de censurer
la liberté d'expression garantie par la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et y
compris quand la constitution c'est
vaste
sébastien meurant merci à vous d'avoir
un petit peu mou à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes sénateur et l'air
et val d'oise merci